هنا في كاسلتاون بير قرية صيد
في الطرف الجنوبي
أه الصيادين الأيرلنديين كانوا يتصدرون
عناوين الصحف الدولية طوال الأسبوع
لوقوفهم في وجه روسيا ، علموا أن
البحرية الروسية ستجري عمليات
تدريبات عسكرية في البحر
على بعد 150 ميلاً من ساحل  أيرلندا
هنا في
وقت لاحق من هذا الأسبوع ، كان الصيادون
قلقين بشأن ذلك لأنهم قالوا إن
ذلك سيعطل سبل عيشهم
وسيؤدي إلى تعطيل مخزون
الأسماك ، وأخبر الصيادون السفير الروسي
هنا
في أيرلندا
أنهم يخططون لمواصلة أعمالهم أنهم
يخططون لمواصلة الصيد حتى  من خلال هذه
التدريبات
اقترح السفير الروسي
أن ذلك سيكون غير حكيم حتى
بالنسبة للصيادين أن يفعلوا ذلك
لكن تغيير في اللهجة الليلة من أه
السفارة الروسية إليكم بيان
أصدروه ردا على
طلبات الحكومة الأيرلندية
بئر من
جنوب وغرب منظمة منتجي الأسماك
الأيرلندية  اتخذ هيرمان
ووزارة الدفاع الروسية
قرارًا
كبادرة حسن نية لنقل
التدريبات وفقًا لخطة البحرية الروسية
لهذا الأسبوع خارج
المنطقة الاقتصادية الأيرلندية الخالصة
بهدف عدم إعاقة أنشطة الصيد
التي تقوم بها السفن الأيرلندية في  مناطق الصيد التقليدية ،
ما يعنيه ذلك بشكل
أساسي
هو أن هذه القوارب الروسية
ستقوم بهذه التمارين بعيدًا
عن الساحل الأيرلندي ،
كنا هنا
نتحدث مع الصيادين طوال اليوم
وكنا هنا
عندما ظهرت هذه الأخبار في
وقت متأخر من مساء يوم السبت هنا في
أيرلندا وهنا  كان رد فعل
أحد الصيادين ، لقد صُدمت حقًا لأنني
لم أكن أعتقد أن القليل منا
جميعًا في جنوب غرب إيران
سيكون له تأثير على
الدبلوماسية
الدولية وسيجعل آه
إحداث تأثير من هذا القبيل وهكذا
يمكن أن تسمع أن هناك
فوزًا حقيقيًا لديفيز في هذا ديفيس أه مقابل
قصة جالوت من الواضح أيضًا أن السفارة الروسية
تشير إلى أن الحكومة الأيرلندية
قد وافقت  شوفهم حول
اه تحريك قواربهم أبعد من
الشاطئ دونيو سوليفان سي إن إن كاسلتاون بير إيرلندا